every single
reason for her trust issues is valid
it's completely valid wrong yeah and
then the movie and the story keeps
staring towards like riots wrong
is wrong no she's not
like she has every reason not to trust
any and she's doing the right thing
by getting this [ __ ] together yeah she's
the one with the right goal but it was
like
no we need to show grace to the
in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain
podcast we have our returning co-host ed
park
in the house today how's it going
life is in do you know what i found out
that kind of
i feel like everybody knows about this
character except for me
but um there's like a new
korean marvel superhero have you heard
of this guy
is it amadeus cho no not amadeus cho
it's this guy he's like he has
his name is tekuki
okay yeah it's the worst costume the
worst
[ __ ] costume it's like man you better
make sure your [ __ ] is clean you're
gonna get this brown sponge in the back
yeah i was just like damn he looks like
he's going to
like he's like a pastor at a funeral or
something like a korean funeral
what the [ __ ] is that i have no idea i
saw this
i was just perusing the other day
because i was looking at the the back
history of amadeus cho
right and why he's somehow the hulk or
whatever and then there was this article
about oh
asians rejoice because we have a new
superhero in town illustrate
this i mean are you trying to sell comic
books in korea like just south korea or
like so that
all american like even us like
understand this guy
but teguki means what flag yeah
oh you're wearing your flag as a costume
like okay
and even on top of that like if if
you're not korean it just sounds like
his name is the [ __ ]
i was like
who the [ __ ] is this guy it's way more
over the top than captain america's
costume even
the new captain america uh how the
falcon is captain and his
his costume is pretty bright right it's
really what dude his cost tiger keys
costume is like
worse ridiculous dude it's just all
white from your
head to your toes well in your neck to
your toes it's it's just
white it's blank i'm sure it's really
easy to draw but well i don't even know
what his super powers are i just stopped
at the name
because i don't i don't know what the
[ __ ] anybody was thinking why would you
call him tekuki you just kind of
get this and like i'm i've lost all
interest in it it's like he's
he can only ever remember like his pain
from the korean war
[Laughter]
he [ __ ] hates the japanese he defeats
hyper capitalist
i mean what what about him he's like so
korean he just beats everybody with a
shoebox
he resents everybody he's super [ __ ]
petty
he always gets revenge he only gets
professionals all that that's how he
solves all of his problems
oh you know what the [ __ ] is this i
don't know man like it says they're
trying too hard i guess
it's just the you know the problem with
when we talked about mulan too right
it's like when the credits roll it's
just all these white people
right besides the cast leading into
the other movie i just saw rhea is like
what like that's the other side of it
though right
it's like let's take all of these 10
countries
and match them into just one culture so
this is the the weird thing right so
when i was watching uh was it raya and
the last dragon that's what it's called
right
you know before these films come out and
especially now
uh with how the climate is everybody is
gunning for this multicultural thing
they're almost like shoving it in our
face right
which riot was really cool when i was
thinking about it conceptually because
it's you know it's southeast asian we
haven't seen like this this
crazy high budget southeast asian
animated film
yeah and there's so much stuff to kind
of tackle right and i think what happens
is with these films and by the way just
the prefaces
i [ __ ] hated the movie yeah nothing
not fancy yeah i know
again you know a lot of people probably
disagree with this
and one of the biggest things that i
keep hearing from people is like well it
was great to be represented
i'm just talking about this as a viewer
right
not as a film critic or whatever it's
just the film was trying to do too much
in like an hour and a half two hour film
it just it was
way too much and that's another thing
yeah um
too much in too little time it was over
in a blink of an eye
yeah right it was kind of it was pretty
short too right
what it really reminded me of was um
the what's it called not the zack
schneider cut the the
that's what the film reminded me of
there's like spots missing it's like
there's there's there's so much
exposition where they just talk
talk talk talk whenever they're on the
boat right every time they got on the
boat i pulled up my phone
not gonna lie i just watched pimple
popping videos
you know that's not guilty pleasure but
i was just like i'd always lose my
interest
yeah so for people who watch this film
right my that's like my biggest
issue with it was the fact that number
one so let's just kind of
bring up the premise of this of this
film right there's uh who was the main
character
rhea okay it was raya right that's how
much i hated the film i watched it
i just i don't remember too much about
it but either way daniel day kim right
who looks his character looks just like
they didn't even try she's like this is
just going to be
darker okay
so there was this um this crazy war that
happened
in in the past right with with these
with these dragons right
um they're revered as the protector and
what they left behind is this remnants
of this stone
right which is the their their last
power the last bit of their existence or
whatever right
uh her father their clan was in
protection of this there's a bunch of
jealousy from other clans all why do you
get to have the stone
right right so they come in they
sabotage it it breaks into a gajillion
pieces and everybody takes it back to
their respective
areas right this is already where the
film is gonna fail because
just like joss whedon's uh
not avengers let's just call it the weed
and cut we'll just call it the weeden
cut right
there's too much [ __ ] to explain in this
short period of time
right and so with throughout this film
they're supposed to go ahead and travel
to all these different countries and
retrieve these stones
but they do it so half-assed because
there's not enough time
for us to care right so sisu uh the
dragon right the [ __ ] my little pony
i thought it was a unicorn the whole
time all these dragons were like furries
man yeah
but um dude she came out of nowhere
like uh raya just finds a shipwreck
and this must be it for some [ __ ]
reason okay
um somehow she knows how to summon them
does not explain you know and just all
these
these factors and then she just kind of
comes up right
she appears but for some reason this
movie
along the way really reminded me of
aladdin
but then the way and the timing that it
took
before genie even showed up like
it was kind of like uh what do you call
it
it was it was thought through yeah you
know until he came and
he became a character into this whole
thing like changing aladdin's life
but with sisu she just kind of
shows up right in the first 15 minutes
right there was like no effort no like
work no
you know the adventure even getting into
it like she was like this is the last
river
for me that sounds like that's the end
of the movie but it's the beginning
right yeah
so where where they find them in the at
the tail right the tail clan area
and comes up and then
yeah they just get that first i don't
know it just kind of happens as it goes
and you don't really get to know people
it's just
they're just there it just is what it is
you know what the weirdest character was
out of nowhere was that [ __ ] baby
baby the baby
what the [ __ ] was that and that's what
it's like i swear that was just a
reincarnation of
a poo into like four monkeys
one of the things that i hate that films
do a lot
it's almost like people create
characters because they know
that this is gonna be a goofy character
that people are gonna talk about
but they don't do any story building for
that character at all
this baby just shows up and starts
[ __ ] people up
and on top of that it's a terrible human
being by the way just stealing people's
[ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy right and like even cesar
was just like
it wasn't had didn't have the charm of
genie
yeah i was getting kind of [ __ ]
annoyed
i was like don't you don't know [ __ ] it
literally knows nothing
and super naive about trust like so the
over-encompassing moral is
trust right the beginning of it uh
reya arya's uh trauma let's say is that
she trusted
this girl and straight up literally
kicked her in the back
you know and then for me like it's like
okay you
idiot like as as she was taking her
there it was already like this is a
dumb but okay this is kind of how she
learns
not to trust people uh her dad gets a
spear to the leg and
can't walk at all or or jump over a
bridge into a safe water right because
they don't like water but
yeah she's like no you go and then i'll
die yeah
and and so you kind of understand oh she
has this trauma of trust now
she can't trust like her father did
because he was wrong
right and what works at least is that
every character she meets from different
clans that joins her team
share the same trauma their loved ones
are stone
now right and they have a hard time
trusting but
for some reason so because of their
shared trauma they
learn to trust each other yeah right the
one person being uh the antagonist girl
with the buzz cut
like she still has a
she's just not trustable right you just
can't trust her except
sisu keeps saying yeah you just have to
buy them a gift
you go to that [ __ ] water town and
you trust
she trusts this old lady and she puts
her behind these gate walls to die
right yeah and for some reason she's
like no we still have to get this girl a
gift it will work
like clearly it doesn't yeah it has a
very distorted view of like
what trust is and what trust issues
exactly
like how it affects people and who's
watching this young kids
yeah you're just telling them yeah go
ahead and trust bill cosby
yeah you know what was really funny that
wasn't even explained
was the fact when um whatever these
demons or whatever that comes to these
shadows right where they come from where
the [ __ ] are they
yeah what is this it's just like this
emerging threat
but then like is is that like the
biggest
thing like where do they come from yeah
i don't even know what they are
and then on top of that when for some
reason in the beginning of the film
everybody else who gets frozen and
turned to stone it looks like they're
begging for money
but then for some reason at the end they
were allowed to stay in their stance
when they were touching each other as
friends
but they weren't they weren't doing this
i was like well how come they don't get
to do that so heartfelt you know
because they trust each other it was
weird like continuity issues
you know what the funniest [ __ ] thing
was too yeah and i started busting out
laughing
was when sisu she was like hey you have
the power this is what it is
and they gave it to her and this is
before they turn to stone why the [ __ ]
she did she do anything
yeah she just waited for them to turn to
the stone and then she [ __ ] destroyed
them i'm like yo wait hold on a second
you had the ability to stop them and you
just watched them die and then you went
now it's time right right that the
biggest issue with that is like
you didn't even earn this like
unsolicited trust like
at every step of the way by the way you
you you [ __ ]
like tricked all these [ __ ] and
like what is it about you [ __ ] kill
the dragon too yeah you don't deserve
[ __ ] yeah and it's it's like the idea is
oh when they go low we go high it's like
good luck sucker like you just have to
hope for an altruism like that she's
going to make the right choice
these weird morality issues
were so prevalent throughout the film it
was very just confusing
especially if this is supposed to be a
kid's film right yeah one of the things
that i had um that i really disliked
was uh the antagonist i forgot her name
like no
nara or something okay like her the
antagonist right
so towards the end of the film uh sisu
is like you
you know she was supposed to trust them
and this is the point where she ambushes
everybody saying that i gotta go ahead
and do my [ __ ] or whatever right
and then once again it goes in the trust
like you just have to trust her
no [ __ ] reason why but you just have
to right even though she's consistently
proven she's a piece of [ __ ] yeah
right everyone's a piece of [ __ ] yeah
everyone everybody is trash
and then towards the end so obviously i
don't know they're trying to show that
she would have done something right but
nobody really [ __ ] knows right
uh it [ __ ] everything up everything
gets [ __ ] up it gets broken the little
the whatever the shard pieces or
whatever
the evil and starts the evil you know
specters start to come
but towards the end of the film for some
reason this piece of [ __ ]
thinks that she has the moral standing
to lecture
the hero of the story like this would
have never happened if you only trusted
me
right who the [ __ ] are you yeah what
have you done you entitled [ __ ]
to exactly to earn anybody's trust
where does why does she get why where is
that that was the weirdest part for me
i'm like hold on a second i mean it's
worse that
raya accepted it yeah yeah maybe you're
just like
it wasn't your fault literally wasn't
your fault she gave you every reason not
to trust her
that is the smart [ __ ] move and on
top of that too she wasn't going to do
the right thing
from what it seemed like anyways yeah
right and so for some reason she
she has the moral high ground to look at
and say like you know what this is
actually your fault because if you would
have trusted me
you should have known that i was going
to do the right thing even though i came
here to kill you
yeah you're so stupid you're so dumb i
can't believe you did it trust me
even though i backstabbed you 18 15
times throughout the whole film yeah
that's [ __ ] manipulating and like
projecting
[ __ ] right like that kind of
behavior but then this podcast is
brought to you by liquid death have you
ever walked in
to one of your local stores and noticed
a random tall boy beer in the water
bottle section
well it was probably liquid death and
it's not beer you dummies it's
fresh ass spring water and let me tell
you something i got like six
cases of this at home and it's legit the
best and funny enough i got pulled over
yesterday while drinking it because this
looks like a beer but it's water but
joke's on you jackass
it's just water baby and if you're
wondering why liquid death
is called liquid death aside from the
fact that you can drink water in front
of your friends who drink beer
and not get persecuted they actually are
trying to bring
death to plastic water bottles plastics
aren't as recyclable as people think
and the majority of the plastic water
balls you recycle end up in a landfill
because it's not
profitable to recycle aluminum is
infinitely recyclable and actually
profitable for recycling facilities so
that's why i [ __ ] with liquid death
legit the sparkling water is one of my
favorite check this out
yes baby
i love it two cases gone in a week i
drink it all the time
i'm not just saying it you're saying it
right here the best so go to
liquiddeth.combrain
to get a free set of koozies with your
first order of
any case of water or you can just grab
some at any whole foods or 7-eleven
make sure you guys cop that liquid death
baby
like then you you would address that
kind of [ __ ] like in some certain way
but no
ryan's like yeah you're right
it is it is my fault and so therefore
she doesn't kill her
yeah and batman's out of there like she
keeps disappearing like the whole moral
of the story is like listen
don't trust what everybody has done to
you in the past
yeah people's behaviors don't really
show who they really are
just go ahead and give everybody the
benefit of the doubt yeah what kind of
[ __ ] moral is that like in the whole
it doesn't make any sense
like every [ __ ] every
single reason for her trust issues is
valid it's completely valid wrong
yeah and then the movie and the story
keeps steering towards
like riots wrong raya's wrong no
she's not like she has every reason not
to trust any
and she's doing the right thing by
getting this [ __ ] together yeah she's
the one with the right goal but it was
like
no we need to show grace to the
the worst of us to prove give them a
chance to prove that they can do the
right
thing really and like and it's kind of
weird because it feels like sisu and
other people are almost like chastising
her like
why didn't you trust her it's like you
know why yeah you were there for
everything
nobody trusts anybody yeah like that's
the point
like even to this day in our society
here in america or even let's say
southeast asia
what's the trust like right unless you
have a country like singapore words
everything's online i just i just don't
know when they created this film what
they expected us to take away from this
right yeah
and when people when people say they
like a film simply because it's
representation it bothers me so [ __ ]
much
right it's not a reason to say that a
film is [ __ ] good just because you
saw people's faces on it
with [ __ ] characters it was a terrible
film yeah it wasn't great
well uh you told me that factoid that
this movie was made
in the pandemic right yeah so 400
artists
made it from their homes yeah right so
that means they don't
have great team meetings and everyone's
responsible for a scene
and then there was chunks missing in
between to fill in
like where they're going where they're
headed instead they were like
they filled it in every time they're in
the [ __ ] boat eating food to talk
about
what's going on what are they feeling
whether it's happening and then
repeating oh i'm a great swimmer i'm a
great swimmer i'm a great swimmer
which by the way none of those [ __ ]
powers that kept coming to her like
and oh yeah [ __ ] oh
i completely forgot about that like what
was the point of you absorbing those
powers you did nothing with it yeah
like [ __ ] was that about glowing didn't
help them at all
uh your fog for some reason wasn't
so cool but i don't know like i felt
like i thought she was going to level up
every time she received the power and it
was so lackluster
no i was super just you know what was
very weird too was like well actually
this is actually my favorite character
was benedict wong's character
right he was so [ __ ] funny dude he
made sense like
because of his stereotype right that
these are big burly men in the mountains
with their big axes right
and when they come across him then he is
exactly that
but then it's showing that he's putting
up this facade
to hide his trauma because his family is
you know [ __ ] frozen in stone that's
that work
that [ __ ] worked but the baby
the baby and the monkeys dude yeah it's
like oh this baby's mom turned the stone
and these monkeys are raising him
let's talk to him
why does his child know how to
communicate with these primates
yeah why how what yeah it's just
like a full-grown adult like is this
even a baby or is this actually a
an adult is it like that guy hezbollah
that
is that what it is it makes no sense man
yeah
and also too like for like a small side
note
because this film was made in pandemic i
am a lot more forgiving
with this right i'm just telling you how
i felt you know despite knowing these
facts
they did have to create a majority of
this film at home because of the
pandemic
and you know those communication issues
is highly evident
in how this film was created there was
actually a very odd scene if you guys go
back and watch the film
when i when i picture southeast asia uh
we think i think a lot of colors
a lot of foliage and one of the scenes
that was very lackluster was when they
were in the kitchen and they're making
tom yum yeah but when you look at the
kitchen the scene is very bare
and that scene too the the um it didn't
look that good
i was like wait what did they skimp out
on the budget in this part
guess what i'm saying so like they
probably had to do it at their home
computers right they didn't have those
giant render farms and
whatever possibly who knows also too
the um the the the voice recordings for
the voice actors
all recorded from home of course it all
sounded weird if you go back and listen
to the film
the audio sounds weird it doesn't sound
um it's
the character's voice acting sounded
very detached because they had to direct
them through zoom calls
yeah yeah of course how hard is that
[ __ ] yeah and so when i was
the the kelly tran her character was
really good when she played raya i think
i thought her voice acting was really
great everybody else sounded a little
disconnected
and i don't think it's to the fault of
the actors or actresses it's because
they were being directed through a zoom
call and it's super [ __ ] hard
apparently there's like four directors
on this movie eight writers
yeah that screams that they didn't they
couldn't get it right
yeah they absolutely couldn't get it
right they had a huge issue
with um they wanted to make sure
that they weren't being disrespectful to
southeast asian culture just because of
how the climate is right yeah
and that's that representation thing
right exactly so when it came to
clothing there was a uh the dragon
so this dragon that's represented in
this film is a
southeast asian dragon there's no wings
and the reason why raya has to walk on
water
is because they actually can't fly
typically in southeast asia right
so in order to stay true to it they kind
of modified it and they made the dragon
walk on water versus having wings and
flying because typically
southeast asian dragons that was a
useful power that came in yeah
towards the end yeah you know there is
like other
like you know i don't know if it's just
me but am i the only one that's [ __ ]
tired of
how we use food as an allegory for us as
people
all the time dude it's it's always about
food
kind of thing and you know with
ratatouille
like they did a beautiful job in in you
know breaking
apart what food does for us as people
and humans but then
it was this one was more or less like
this represents us
this salty this here this here and it's
like we're all different flavors
salty your mom's a [ __ ] sour because
your grandma hates me
i'm the sweet one i'm the sugar yeah
yeah
i mean even the i don't know like
because there's
so many cultures amalgamated into one
right is that a great representation for
southeast asians the same way you know
we
when they say asian american most people
just think east asian right yeah and
then not only that
just all chinese yeah like
when where's the disney movie where
it's just all of europe all matched
together true
no like uh little mermaids like german
you know
frozen is the scandinavian things [ __ ]
ton of stuff is [ __ ] england
you know well this is what happens too
right there i think people
are forgetting too by the way it's like
you're you're so
focused on not trying to offend somebody
that that becomes
the main focus of your film like you're
deterring from the fact that you still
have to make a good
story yeah and like the representation
stuff is fantastic but don't forget
at the end of the day you're still
creating this art piece it's still film
it still has to go through the same
[ __ ] that all other films have to go
through in order to create a good
final piece right and because of that
because they're mashing all these
cultures together in my personal opinion
and they're trying to do this whole
thing where they have 10 different
nations like his [ __ ] avatar yeah
right
they're trying to do that within an hour
avatar had multiple nations they had to
do that over a series of like four
seasons right right
you tried to do that in about an hour
and a half to two hours how the [ __ ] are
you going to do that
these characters don't have backstory so
when that ending happened and she was
over here telling
raya how to live her life and these
people were all getting [ __ ] up
i could care [ __ ] less i didn't care
about anybody in this film
i didn't care if anybody died or turned
to stone or whatever or if the entire
universe just went to [ __ ]
and it was just run by that purple fart
yeah you know like
who cares doesn't matter what is it like
it's the purple
yeah it's so unreal it's just like you
don't even care if they come out okay
but you know sisu comes back to life for
no [ __ ] reason
why right and all the dragons all
together because
because humans finally learn to trust
each other yeah
meanwhile at the end they're all they
actually are one giant nation now right
except that hey weren't you that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that tried to
kill me yeah like old lady who tried to
put the [ __ ] season behind like you
try to kill
people yeah instead you're just walking
and you're going to have your tom yum
soup
you're just like this movie's [ __ ] it
doesn't make any sense
like the it showed the worst qualities
in human beings
and it didn't like i just don't
understand why raya was wrong
don't forget she was the only good
person
despite all the stuff that was happening
she was trying to do the right thing and
carry out her father's wish of unifying
this country that's the right thing to
do people were continually showing how
[ __ ] up of human beings they are right
they had no redeeming qualities to show
that she should show trust to them
because in reality why the [ __ ] would
you ever give somebody a hundred percent
of your trust when they haven't tried to
murder you multiple yes
it doesn't make any sense just had a
[ __ ] sword fight any one of you could
have had a limb cut off and you're like
you know what
go ahead like like the crux of the film
too right everybody's getting frozen and
jacked up and then she just goes
all right i guess it's got to be you
here you
did you take this you guys like a
reverse guardians of the galaxy yeah
right the purple the [ __ ] [ __ ] flying
around let's all [ __ ] hold hands
except
we all die i still want to know why the
who the purple farts are who are they
yeah
it it like i mean i keep going to
aladdin with this
um because you know at least jafar
you know or even steppenwolf what was
the problem with stephen wolf was
originally in the weeding cut was he's
just a big burly
guy who's here to destroy [ __ ] and you
got to stop him morals the earth's gone
right and then so
nobody [ __ ] cares about that right
yeah and then when they
when the zack snyder cut of justice
league oh
he's actually he's trying to go home
he's got a purpose he has a trauma too
he's got his own goal he doesn't even
really give a [ __ ] about earth
you know but and so there's actually
a complexity to it like their motivation
to why they do their things right
and even jafar because simply he wants
to be sultan he wants to rule the world
he wants power
what do these [ __ ] purple farts want
yes
where did they come from there's no
[ __ ] reason yeah i
i want there to be a new cut of raya
where they kind of just break down
i want there to be a four hour cut yeah
i
it has to be better because you'll get
to see the different nations you'll get
to see character motivation
and that was the same reason why [ __ ]
zack snyder's cut was so much better
there were so many i don't even think we
talked about that right yeah
we were supposed to multiple times but
if we could move on to that
what zack schneider did in terms of his
cut was so much better
like it it took me a while to watch the
film because
i was like four hours i'm not going to
watch this i go to hawaii i have to be
in the plane for [ __ ] five hours
either way
i'm gonna watch it i've i've now watched
the zack snyder cut four times yeah
dude same way man i've seen it multiple
times i had to watch it overnight
so beautiful and you don't even need to
watch it in one go you can watch it
chapter by chapter yeah like like it's a
full
series yeah it was so [ __ ] good it
actually
okay there's okay can i don't even
understand
why in the joss whedon cut why he cut
certain parts out
it doesn't make sense all right can i be
like you one day
he's like of course nope cut that [ __ ]
out
why why did he why did he cut this [ __ ]
out why did you cut out [ __ ] um
robots in that robot cyborg cyborg
cyborg's
whole backstory in jos we just cut
i don't know why the [ __ ] he was there
yeah he had almost no purpose it was
like
he just he just turned him into a
second-rate iron man with
like literally nothing to go for i think
i was right
and this was a while back though but
joss whedon
disliked zack schneider [ __ ] yeah and he
was just adamant
about saying you know what i could do
this better than you all his [ __ ] is
[ __ ]
which clearly wasn't the case yeah one
of the i so i went back and i rewatched
josh whedon's cut
it's a parody film right it's hilarious
it's a satire even the coloring is weird
yeah right everyone's got rosy cheeks
you know what the dumbest
part that was changed that he didn't
have to change at all because for sure
they already shot this on the zack
snyder cut yeah
was when the amazonians first
encountered
steppenwolf right he made the women look
so [ __ ] weak weak as [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] was that
really [ __ ] weak and lame and
just like a satire of strong women
right but meanwhile when you when you
watch the snyder cut
it's [ __ ] 300 with the women and
they're like
they have they're [ __ ] fearless you
know and they're
they're going in overpowered with
[ __ ] courage like it's somehow
shown through in his cut but meanwhile
in in
the we didn't cut he's just dropping
them like flies he
makes them super weak like pew like let
me tell you something look stupid for
using arrows
like i very very rarely talk about
sexism right yeah that's some sexist
[ __ ] yeah that [ __ ]
actually pissed me off when i saw the
zack schneider cut because i haven't
seen that cut the josh sweden one in so
long
my i didn't it was so dope when
when steppenwolf came in and he was like
i smell fierce
what the [ __ ] you talking about [ __ ] we
don't have fear they start banging on
their shields right
and one of the coolest moments in that
film is when they decided that you know
what
in order for us to just push for justice
and do the right thing we're gonna
sacrifice ourselves
and they decide to take out that whole
[ __ ] building and the whole
mountainside
in order for them to do the right thing
yeah that was
amazing yeah cut to joss whedon
they just closed the door they just
rushed it like get out of here
they're like okay we're just gonna close
this door and then see what happens
no mistakes there's no sticks like no
uh no no what a despair for the fact
that hundreds of of her people just died
yeah just gave up their lives
um to to fight this and then the despair
when
when steppenwolf is still alive you know
like that kind of emotion
is is run through in his version but
we didn't cut he's just it's a real if
you go back and watch it's a really
weird rush
cgi job he busts through the wall yeah
and he starts chasing them but it's just
like the solution was what like this guy
just
transported himself from another [ __ ]
dimension
and then this stone wall is going to
stop him yeah like that's how stupid the
amazonians are they're just like
close the door see what happens yeah see
if he gets out
let's see yeah exactly so i i did my own
research too just be like
how could you do this on purpose yeah
right and all the
stories on set was like joss whedon was
being a super [ __ ] [ __ ] on set
like talking [ __ ] about zack snyder and
how he saw zack snyder's version and
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] right
but here's the thing with these josh
sweden reshoots right on set
these are all the same people who made
the version you just saw and you're
talking [ __ ] to the people who made it
that's [ __ ] he's the only new guy
there
and that's the prop that was the problem
that the actor ray
fisher was complaining about josh mean
was just like he was crazy
unprofessional and he was a [ __ ]
racist
you know oh really so it's like not only
did he take away
um cyborg's story um
and his whole background and and his
motivations
and all that he actually cut out almost
every other black actor
in the film oh for real cyborg yeah
and in the meantime he was just like he
kept taking away wonder woman's god
goddessness just being a [ __ ] god
amongst men
and just kind of weakened her like
made her look like a [ __ ] uh satire
of herself
you know with these stupid jokes they he
pulled off the same [ __ ] joke he did
in age of ultron where
a dude falls in a girl's breast right
the hulk
bruce banner falls on scarlet black
widow's boobs right
for some [ __ ] reason he he brings it
back where flash falls on wonder woman's
boobs
and gal gadot actually refused to do it
so much that had a stunt double do it
for her that's crazy yeah
it's just like why you know why i just
i see now that makes sense because i
went that amazonian scene was
so was probably one of my favorite
scenes in the [ __ ] film yeah
just because it was just so cool to see
how they just didn't give a [ __ ] they're
like dude
we're amazonian warriors and we're going
to show you what's up even though they
knew they were overpowered
and it's kind of weird too like when the
bank scene too right
he cut out half the fight scene yeah
what the [ __ ]
he cut out like well and he added a dumb
part too where
um you won't see in the zack snyder
version but then
in the jaw speeding cut someone hits her
in the back of the head with
his gun stock oh yeah yeah he doesn't
faze her right
but dude you have [ __ ] bullets
if you were that close just [ __ ]
point that [ __ ] and brow
right i i don't know and
like i said he just nerfed them just
made them look like parodies themselves
the flash scene
oh the the uh when he was in the speed
at that very end
why would you cut that out i have no
[ __ ] idea dude i was like almost
crying as when i first saw that i was
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
and like why he was doing it why he had
to do it and like
his pain through and like how he's
thinking of his dad as
he's doing it and even that line like i
felt like that was like kind of
that was so [ __ ] beautiful he's like
nope
all this needs to go i i mean at this
point is he just doing it just to say
[ __ ] you zach schneider because that's
like the only reason why
i could imagine why somebody would look
at something that's better than his and
go you know what
i'm just going to ruin this yeah it's
like [ __ ] you zack snyder
[ __ ] you women and [ __ ] black people
that's
that's the message i get every time i
see the joss whedon version
you know what's crazy too just the idea
of
what he did to cyborg's character
and kind of like how the purpose of his
father was so different in the zack
snyder cut
right the zack snyderka was so much
better it made sense
yeah it [ __ ] made sense like it made
sense why his dad was doing what he was
doing
and also made you feel for his character
a lot more too yeah because before it
was just like
he was just like i hate you dad yeah
he was just strange with his father
there was no [ __ ] resolution
so so in in we didn't cut then why go
save your dad after he gets kidnapped
right and
and there's yeah there's a difference
where despite his
like his anger or whatever he like he's
going to do the right thing for
like that for his father and save him
and like i think i saw it on youtube
like oh the differences
between the weeding cut and the snyder
cut
where um when steppenwolf's about to
kill his father cyborg's father
like it becomes like oh i can't control
my body
yeah and it automatically saves him
right because his body wants to
but in zack snyder's cut he's like he
freaks [ __ ] out he goes no
yeah bam and blast him like that means
so much more
same fight where um what's a
flash kind of like uh i don't really
fight anybody and then batman goes
save one save one person and that's all
it takes one at a time
but then in the zack snyder version he's
just
[ __ ] saving everybody he's just
[ __ ] doing it because it's
in their [ __ ] characters the
difference with
um the justice league and the avengers
right
is the idea that these are gods amongst
men
like when [ __ ] goes down and the justice
league shows up the avengers would
[ __ ] skedaddle like cockroaches
compared to these people but yeah nope
just nerf them make them look like fools
make matt batman tell
stupid-ass one-liner jokes well dude the
jokes were so
stupid they're so stupid and out of
place
and also too here's one scene that
really didn't make any sense after i
went back
was when the the whole idea of
steppenwolf in that film which by the
way
joss whedon steppenwolf is just there
for no reason yeah he just showed up he
goes
i'm just here to kick ass where's my mom
not my mother where's mother that's
really what it is right
but steppenwolf's whole thing is that
the reason why he's the man in charge is
because this guy
has no sense of fear that's why he can
control all these little [ __ ] bugs or
whatever the [ __ ] they are these little
demon bugs
uh there was a very odd scene and flash
before he went into the building right
he said i'm so [ __ ] scared well i
thought these things can smell fear yeah
they know you're right outside like five
feet away
what the [ __ ] are you talking about that
made no sense why would you put that in
there that it
literally doesn't make sense to the
characters it doesn't make sense to why
steppenwolf
is so dope or why those monsters even
attack people they literally feed off of
fear
right and he said i'm so [ __ ] scared
i'm scared shitless he's like as far as
like i am to this damn door
and to even top that off the ending was
so stupid
steppenwolf is scared so the bugs start
eating him yeah and you don't really
that's it no not that like [ __ ]
superman beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
him
you know it's just he's scared like
take him away that's it that's it it
took like five of you guys to actually
take care of this guy
yeah but me but you're actually all
scared of him i don't know
so they didn't even really defeat him he
defeated himself how stupid is that
how [ __ ] dumb is that [ __ ] the zack
snyder cut
he got an axe he got a sword to the
[ __ ] head got chopped off and it
rolled right in front of a dark side's
face
amazing right and even the fact that
they [ __ ] fail
they fail first because um whether their
teamwork wasn't right or whatever like
the the [ __ ] weight of
the urgency and all that [ __ ] like what
it takes
it really brings into mold like flash's
character and
and like his [ __ ] true power like
that
the potential that we could see like
with what he does
which leads into the flashpoint paradox
his
his solo movie which is going to be
[ __ ] awesome yeah well at least the
original story and the animated movie is
but now i just like
don't trust it because they're not going
to continue the snyder verse they're
going to keep going with as if
joss whedon's movie is canon
i can't but zach standard doesn't want
to continue the film anymore
i think he does i mean that's why he
left it open-ended to have like
um where they have these flashes of the
future oh what's gonna like it's the
injustice future
have you played that game i haven't
played the game but
just watching the the the snippet at the
end
i had to go ahead and look it up and see
what the [ __ ] was going on
because it was insane yeah like what the
[ __ ] just happened
so [ __ ] well spoilers if you want to
talk about it like
um something where it's like the joker
tricks superman into
killing lois lane and
that's when superman because and that's
explains man of steel
batman be superman like where he just
has this struggle of like wanting to be
this
hero for the world or whatever and
so when that happens superman's just
like [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it then i'm gonna be your god i'm
the king of the world
listen do what i [ __ ] say and we'll
have peace you know and he
rules the earth now that's [ __ ]
interesting you know
and then no warner brothers like nah
they kendrick cavill's not superman
anymore you know
ben affleck apparently is not going to
be batman anymore on this ship there's
just like
they have this inconsistent like
storyline
this inconsistent universe like x-men is
crazy
you know what irritated me about flash
is is that he went through all the
trouble
to travel back in time and he had to say
the most cryptic message to batman
he was like lois lane is the key why
couldn't you have said something that
was more understandable
you [ __ ] [ __ ] she's like she's the
gay he's like what
love disappears am i too soon
like that whole part had was so
uh the injustice future doesn't happen
right
well it does it does happen he's doing
that to warn him about it
yeah because things are gonna get so
[ __ ] up
he has to go back in time to try to save
lois lane
but he he goes way too far
back or early or something yeah yeah
he's not at the right time
and and so he [ __ ] up basically and
that's all part of the story that could
have unfolded like
but i don't know maybe it's because
audiences did complain about batman v
superman it's
not superb you know but it's still
within the cannons or the cannon the
consistency of where he's trying to take
it at least
but it is weird because i felt that when
when i was younger right
i remember we had our superhero films
right we had the
original superman film which was
christopher reeves with christopher
reeves
which was really cool at the time yeah
but because of technology we get to see
some of the most
amazing comic book superhero film yes of
all time right
and in my mind i was thinking to myself
no matter how bad these films are
i'm still gonna like it because of how
cool it looks compared to the other
stuff yeah
and you know in in that vein i still do
enjoy it because i was
never able to see these things outside
of what my imagination told me when i
read comic books right
so when i see these films when they
disappoint me i get a little mad
i'm like you know there's it's already
laid out for you
the story's already laid out for you
what are you doing dude like isn't that
why you have comic books because you
already have like a skeleton yeah of it
instead yours
oh it won't translate the screen we
gotta make it
dumber yeah does it have to be that it
really doesn't though like batman vs
superman could have been
a really good film you know what the
one thing could have saved the movie if
when batman had him against the ropes
had that
kryptonite spear to his face he says
like you're not a human right yeah like
you were never
you were or you're not a man you were
never even human
right so he's ready to kill him and then
what does he say
save martha right yeah and that's
everyone's [ __ ] problem
i'm like dude if superman was just there
and he says
you're not a man you weren't even human
and he goes save my mom
yeah you know if he's pleading for his
mom that
instantly humanizes him instead save
martha like
who the [ __ ] is martha why not just
who the [ __ ] calls their mom martha by
their first name dude you jackass
makes no sense
i mean if if if his mom had a much more
like unique
name you know then i guess it's like
what the [ __ ] like
yeah that name is the name of my mom
yeah
that's what stops you you jackass is the
fact that your mom shares the same name
what the [ __ ] does that mean
everyone's got a problem with that it
just doesn't doesn't translate at all
like how does that make you a human
batman
it was just so stupid too i think like
also the batman character too i think
he's just a really rich guy yeah yeah
you know
look at all the billionaires in the
world now none of them are anything near
bruce wayne or tony stark i know they're
not about going out there and actually
making the world better yeah you have
elon musk just [ __ ] with crypto all
day yeah
just being a troll you know that's what
we have this guy just [ __ ] with like
the crypto market and just pumping up
doge that's
that's what we have yeah i don't know
like batman character batman's character
was always a little odd for me like he's
just
this neurotic billionaire
right he's just scared all the time he's
just [ __ ] people [ __ ] up
and he refuses to kill people because
why because that's not what good guys
could do
cause guns killed my parents so
i shouldn't do but he's no problem
torturing people
to get what he wants it just it's so
breaks people's fingers so there's
actually this superhero series on
netflix
that kind of dives into this concept the
show is very whatever right but it's
basically
these superheroes who gain their power
through some kind of ancient thing or
whatever right
and this is like during like the early
the early 1950s or some [ __ ] or whatever
1940s
and so now there's new superheroes that
are involved well
this new generation of superheroes are
irritated or upset
at this old generation because they set
the rules that you cannot kill
it doesn't matter us killing makes us
the bad guys right
right however what's happening is that
because they won't kill
these these inherently terrible they
have no reason or want to change
they're just bad people these are just
super villains right they're killing
constantly
and their objective is to kill people
and they're like well why can't we just
kill them
their objective is to kill everybody on
earth they're very selfish they're
killing people
we should just kill them we'll it'll
solve problems and so they're watching
their friends die
and that is a very good question it's
like if you had an ability to stop these
human beings or these these creatures or
whatever
these super villains why not [ __ ] do
it well that was the crux of batman v
superman though
was everyone was complaining that batman
was killing in that movie because he was
[ __ ]
you know he was using guns and killing
right and
i think so that superman had a problem
with batman
enacting his own justice and being judge
jury
executioner like when he would brand
prisoners that means
a death sentence once you get into
prison they'll shank you kind of thing
and so superman's trying to get us to
stop that and that's in the ultimate cut
that actually expands
that's the reason why they're beefing in
the first place it kind of gets lost
and so what ended up happening was that
people were just complaining that batman
was killing
but the that was the problem yeah that's
part of the story
it kind of stems like coming out from
the you've seen watchmen
zack snyder's yes version so i love
watchmen too and if you get when's the
last time you've seen it it's been a
long time you gotta see it again i
[ __ ] love it because uh especially
the original comic
um it's it's kind of basing off the fact
if
like superheroes were real in in
this reality right how would they
actually behave like why would they
dress up in the first place
you know why would they have to team up
in these things so
there's the character dr manhattan right
he's supposed to represent
superman right if there was a real
superman here and he had this
crazy power right he wouldn't give a
[ __ ] about us
yeah you know he would cons he would
just lose his humanity
if he was a god amongst men he'd just
get tired of us in our [ __ ]
you know and he just [ __ ] leave the
mars yeah you know
and then um three other characters
represent
batman you know um rorschach
is the the great detective right
the guy on the street like if there was
really a guy like that
he'd be homeless he'd be crazy he'd have
massive trauma in his head he'd torture
people
that's a [ __ ] up guy right and then
there's
batman the um engineering genius he's
night owl right he's a [ __ ] nerd he
can't get laid
he can't get his dick up he's just kind
of squirmy
you know un until he's like angry or
some [ __ ] i don't know
and then it there's the other split with
ozymandias
right the billionaire what bruce uh
wayne
what would it really be like this gay
flamboyant
super smart capitalist in order to fund
all this [ __ ]
yeah you know and that's i think zack
snyder was taking those philosophies
and then bringing it into this zack
snyder universe like batman would be
this way because this superman
would have a struggle between wanting to
save humanity at all because why the
[ __ ] would he care about us
yeah you know that's what i love about
where he was taking it
and it's just sad to see there's cutting
it it's over and that's kind of what
that a cartoon invincible touches on
right
yes it's where um well the backstory
that he tells his
kid is essentially kind of what
kal-el's parents are telling him it's
like well you have a responsibility
to help these people this is this is why
you're here yeah even though the real
reason is that his [ __ ] planet
exploded he got shot out into [ __ ]
outer space and he
landed some random place yeah which is
really what it is right so i don't even
know how the superman story became to
where he
his parents like you have to be the
savior i don't really get that part but
and that's the story that in in the
invincible cartoon if you guys don't
know there's this
um uh comic book series that kind of
it's really dark
it's it's very [ __ ] dark right and it
talks about just kind of what people do
when they have a certain level of
omnipotence they roll with an iron
[ __ ] fist
you do what we [ __ ] tell you because
we know better you're not who the [ __ ]
are you your aunts yeah why
wouldn't superman be authoritarian you
know
to be like you guys are [ __ ] idiots
and you guys are [ __ ] [ __ ] up i have
all the power in the world if you don't
listen to me i will [ __ ] you up too
yeah right like that and you know with
the whole invincible thing it's
that's how he treats them the the main
character if spoiler alert if you guys
haven't seen this you guys should watch
you can see it on amazon
amazon prime right but this guy who is a
superhero he
kind of tells his kid essentially he's
going to get powers too when he becomes
an adult
um but in the meantime he's gathering
all these other superheroes and he's
actually seen as a beacon of light like
people think he's a really good guy
well in the very first episode i almost
threw up because he
literally [ __ ] gathers
all these top superheroes and kills them
and throughout the whole series you're
basically finding out the reason why
and the reason why is because he's
actually said to earth not as a savior
but to subjugate them yes
right because these people really
believe in their omnipotence
they are the ones that know better we
are gods yeah
and the way that he expec like expends
human life in this [ __ ] series is a
ridiculous dude
literally there's a point where he grabs
his son who also has crazy powers just
like him
puts him in front of a train and has the
train smashed into his sons
guts and then because his son is like
superman
basically he rips into a bunch of people
throughout the training you see guts and
blood everywhere
just to tell his son this is how
insignificant human life is compared to
you
their life disappears in a matter of
what is spanish 70 80 years
you will be here for the next 2000 years
and like how
it's not that far-fetched to believe
somebody like that i mean like
just look at how america tries to spread
democracy
oh yeah trump bombs and all of a sudden
now we run your government right
like people with power you know
would want those resources and all these
things but
what is he also trying to explain too
he's like we're gonna bring our
technology to you you guys will be
live way longer life spans and you will
have you'll be happier yeah you'll be
happy you will actually have real peace
and none of this [ __ ] we just have
to let this happen first
yeah we got to take over right
colonialism yeah
we know better hey this is jesus christ
you know
you know jesus christ he said if you
don't believe in jesus we kill you
you keep a praying to tupayer and an
eagle-faced guy yeah
it doesn't exist it's a good jesus
christ
that's the crazy thing imagine it's it's
really what it is it's about like
colonialism it's like i know better
these are
this is my god and if you don't [ __ ]
believe me you're gonna [ __ ] die you
piece of [ __ ]
yeah and it's part of like this [ __ ]
dark side of human behavior that we do
to
control others that's why i love these
alternate comic book series right
because
i i think um whoever created these past
superheroes before
it kind of just it was rooted in fantasy
yeah right there there aren't any real
consequences for people
black and white he's bad because he's
bad
they're good because they're just good
you know
and the good people will always win but
then you know real human beings are very
complex
there's a reason why everybody does
something right there's a reason why we
have to empathize with other people
and that's how great movies are told
yeah you know villains for the sake of
being a [ __ ] villain
doesn't really create a great villain
doesn't create a great antagonist
yeah i.e going back to zack snyder's cut
and steppenwolf
he had a reason why he was such a
[ __ ] jackass
he just wants to go home yeah and he has
to prove himself to darkseid that
he deserves to come back for the
mistakes that he made your debt
yeah and so it's on his [ __ ] back
that he's got it that's why he
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about the earth
he just wants to get
this was a means to an end that right
there if they if if i
could just take one thing from zack
snyder's cut i would at least put that
in
then it would have just made more sense
yeah because
there was no reason for steppenwolf to
be the way that he was
right he's just i'm here to [ __ ] cut
we didn't cut it was so stupid
it made no sense for josh whedon to take
that part out no sense
at all what the [ __ ] was he thinking
yeah even
like i don't know if he was just trying
to make it less violent maybe
look and just can't be you know the fact
that
um she [ __ ] destroys that um
that terrorist dude like just straight
blasts him through the wall
yeah you know like took that out like uh
i guess it was too violent
or whatever i don't know or just to nerf
you know wonder woman and then following
that is when that girl is like can i be
like you
one day or whatever cut that out yeah
something that kind of shows
um that she's a deity and she's a god
you know it shows how dope she is yeah
she kind of gives hope to people that
she that's her
that's her position she's wonder woman
we need them we need her
like we need these superheroes to help
us like that
that just gets taken out then and then
they also took out the reason why wonder
woman happens to know
this whole backstory to steppenwolf they
took that whole part out
in in in the original cut she just knows
everything
you know she goes i know why he's here i
was like how do you know i [ __ ] know
you don't know this [ __ ] i [ __ ] know
the reason why he's like it's or
it's like it's we got to do this before
it's too late it's already too late well
how do you know because i [ __ ] know
that's what
and like because of that bunch like the
[ __ ] mother box get taken off screen
you know when they revive superman and
he comes back and then
this the boom tube comes down and then
and then he goes away
he took the box like why the [ __ ]
weren't you taking care of it
yeah it's like wasn't that the huge
mcguffin for you like
whatever and then it's but then in the
snyder cut it's like an extra 20 30
minutes of
them of fighting over and his uh
cyborg's that sacrifice
and the exact reason why you know he did
what he did because it was like
this [ __ ] is gonna take it they
gotta he has to
burn it up so it at least sends out this
signal
and then now cyborg has this um next
level more
motivation for why he has to see this
through you know like
he just cut all that [ __ ] out i just i
will never run joss whedon you could
suck my [ __ ] nuts dude
i i hate you so much well i mean just
because
when you when you hear all the stories
about why he did it it was just to be
spiteful just to be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude just being an [ __ ]
afraid dude i read that zack schneider
one of the bigger reasons why he decided
to leave was because of his daughter
right daughter
his daughter um committed suicide yes
how [ __ ] terrible is that and i guess
because when you when you work with such
a major franchise
you know it's it's pretty stressful
you're not just there to make a film
you're there to make them [ __ ] money
right so you have to go through a lot of
red tape you have to go ahead it goes
through a lot of people's hands
and so you know zack snyder as a creator
wants to create something amazing it's
gonna have to be longer than two hours
to make the story make sense
and you know after the passing of his
adopted daughter
he was just like what the [ __ ] am i
stressing out about this [ __ ] for [ __ ]
this
you know like i just lost my daughter i
don't want to deal with this [ __ ]
whatever [ __ ] apparently he's staying
on for like two more months trying to
finish it
wow trying to just putting his head down
to work until they were just like yeah
like so he was just like yeah he just
kind of gave it up but
so one of the stories is that um he
never saw it
the the wheeling cut zack snyder's never
seen it you know
like so when he went in to make finish
his movie it was just i'm just finishing
it this was
his fir his vision from the start you
know and it was because uh
christopher nolan saw it saw the weeding
cut apparently
and when he got out he immediately
phoned zach and he's like you can't
watch this
don't watch it you're gonna be pissed
pretty much
him and his wife are deborah snyder is
the producers of all his movies
she even told him like don't watch it
like don't watch it i mean that sucks
because it's her daughter too and she's
had to see it through but part of a job
is to
see it go through and like to watch that
in the end holy [ __ ] would have been so
[ __ ] offensive
you know that's crazy i felt so bad for
the new man it's like this
this movie comes out that he works super
hard on it turns out to be trash
right because he got butchered he loses
his daughter and then he's just he has
to figure out what's important to him he
goes
dog my family's suffering right now [ __ ]
this film dude that's the hardest part
man
we actually know somebody right now who
was asked to
was like in the first round of being
asked to direct
uh shang qi right right and he decided
not to do it because he was like no
the [ __ ] this is an asian character with
a stick
he goes he's like give me a give us can
we get a real super [ __ ] you know
he's so upset
because when i was asking him i was like
dude why didn't you [ __ ] take it he
goes like well number one like i had
i've never worked with the film this
type of budget and number two
who the [ __ ] is this guy like who is
this guy right
dog i was i was so i was laughing so
hard
when i saw the action figure that came
out for shang chi yeah
it just looks he it's just an asian dude
with a stick
oh bro it's actually kind of hilarious
it honestly honestly if you would have
just took the stick and you would have
put a broom at the end of it it would
have made more sense i wonder what
little kids
are gonna do with that little you know
he's better probably gonna you know put
a magnifying glass to it
what good is he you know what it is he's
gonna be donatello in [ __ ] uh ninja
turtles
what he wanted donatello everybody had a
dope [ __ ] weapon
and then donatello has purple and he
hasn't
[ __ ] this guy over so bad and they did
that with the shane she character like
this action figure
is simulu with the stick it's like what
the [ __ ] man
that's that's another thing too like are
we
am i getting tired like the same way
with us being an allegory to food like
do we have too much kung fu associated
with everything we
do yeah you know um i don't know
it i'm kind of getting over it but then
and that's what i'm afraid of with the
shang chi
like i have no expectations i'm not
gonna say it's
our our version of black panther yet you
know
i i gotta tell you i saw that trailer
it's not gonna be our version of black
panther
if the if the trailer is indicative of
how good a film is supposed to be
and they started off with this fool and
his hand hitting a
[ __ ] pole right it's like that's the
best opening you could give us for our
superhero you [ __ ] faces
disappointed father you know yeah again
and
yeah there's a lot of tropes but i'm
assuming because marvel does a lot of
like to do things out of left foot like
their trailers don't actually say
anything about the movies which is great
then i would have to expect that they're
going to
like destroy those expectations yeah um
hopefully i really do like we wanted to
win
yeah but we just we've been burned so
much
yeah and every every major asian film
not not every i'm being
extremely hyperbolic right here but i
think it's because
we just expect us to always do kung fu
and martial arts listen i'm not mad at
that [ __ ] right
like if if if we're doing martial arts
film damn straight it should be us
that's something
that we originated in like that's what
we created we created martial arts
that's [ __ ] dope but i've seen it so
many [ __ ] times i don't know how many
times i could watch it over and over
again
yeah i have my classics it's kind of
like how
much breakdancing can i watch
when i watch battle of the year back and
they you know by the time you get
towards the end it's like how many more
windmills and flares
maybe it's like that you know unless
they they got
[ __ ] i don't know if they got donnie
and or jackie chan or
you and mo ping like to be the car do
something dope do something we haven't
seen or
do something we haven't seen since
crouching tiger oh it's just gonna or
maybe they'll just do it like mulan
where just
gently doesn't do [ __ ] i don't even know
it was jet li
[Laughter]
dubbed the voice so this is a dubbed
[ __ ] voice and then donnie yen
is just this one fight scene and it
shows us how well he handles swords
apparently in that film too the uh the
the fight choreographer was telling
daniel what the deal he goes this is
terrible
he just does his whole thing and it was
the probably the best fight choreography
in the film
right but the the problem being with
mulan was that when you have this
choreography
the cinematography and editing has to go
with it there's a hong kong style
there's a this wusha style of
filming and editing you know this stuff
so
i really hope that it's gonna come out
clear not like
the [ __ ] super close up shaky cam cut
cut cut cut with every hit
and like you have to that's the thing
too like you do that for people who
don't know how to
fight they they're not well versed in
fight choreography
great example of that is what it was
well jason stanley can apparently
actually fight
but that style i saw the most in every
jason statham film
yeah the [ __ ] quick whips and
everything else and it masked
all the movement yeah which when it
comes to the lucha style you actually
get to see the choreography from a wide
angle right that's the beauty of it
right there's a [ __ ] rhythm
and with the music too and it's a wide
long shot and like
and then you see american jackie chan
films it's
cut cut cut cut and the edit is the pace
exactly it's not like a theater
kind of show where you're seeing a corey
choreographed dance but it's martial
arts
and that's what crouching tiger is more
or less like which is why it's so
beautiful these
wide shots and you see it's them it's
michelle yo
and and uh
yeah yeah it's them they are classically
trained
like in choreography and dance and
that's how they treated it when they had
their fight scene it's
[ __ ] awesome too yeah yeah till this
day i don't think there will ever be
another martial arts film as beautiful
as crouching tiger hidden dragon
and i heard angley was asked to direct
mulan and he was like nah nah
he would not he would know he's like
this is just ccp [ __ ] dude
he's like i'm not doing this [ __ ] dude i
refuse which
man if he did mulan could you imagine
how dope that [ __ ] would have been it
would have been [ __ ] awesome
but at the same time you know china
would have banned it
yeah they would have been when i watched
cochran tiger hidden dragon i
i always refer back to that scene where
they were chasing each other on the roof
yeah it was just so beautiful it was
very poetic everything in that film the
choreography was like
it was like watching dance choreography
yeah like they're they're flying on top
of trees
right it's like okay but then there was
a rhyme and reason like and there was a
beauty to it
like everything like having purpose
instead of just
on the script it says and now they fight
yeah fight scene
that feels so good dude yeah well guys
uh that wraps up this episode of the
genius brain podcast we went over
the zack schneider cut i know i shat
on raya pretty [ __ ] hard if you like
the film sorry
let us let us know what you what you
absolutely loved about it try to do it
without saying yeah you represented me
let's talk about why you like the film
huh yeah and once again if you like it
it's all
it's all good dude i hate you
[Laughter]
but you can catch ed at edparkvp
um and uh everything at parkvp actually
yeah
right and then every thursdays and
sundays we'll catch you guys next time
bye